avec nous sur ce plateau ce matin
matthieu mabin bonjour mathieu bonjour
et bienvenue chez vous monsieur vous
êtes notre correspondant à washington
vous avez suivi depuis le 24 février et
le début de l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine les briefings quotidiens du
pentagone comment est-ce que mathieu
l'état-major américain comprend et
communiquent sur la stratégie militaire
russe en ukraine alors d'abord ils nous
ont imposé de rompre avec une habitude
qui était de prendre les informations du
pentagone avec méfiance puisque
l'histoire nous enseigne et qu'il
fallait être méfiant on se souvient tous
de l'épisode irakiens notamment pour le
plus récent mais plus plus en amont la
guerre du golfe qui réellement nous
encourager à être méfiants avec ce
qu'avec la communication du pentagone et
puis cette fois il ya eu les
déclarations de la maison blanche qui
ont annoncé l'offensive qui martelaient
cette information et qui suscitait
parfois on s'en souvient le doute ici en
europe et notamment dans la diplomatie
européenne on se souvient du président
zelensky qui demandait au président
biden d'arrêter de mettre de l'huile sur
le feu diplomatique et puis tout s'est
vérifié donc évidemment nous les
observateurs on a changé de posture est
désormais on prend les comptes rendus de
renseignements qui sont littéralement
converti en communiqué de presse est
donc finalement dépêche beaucoup plus au
sérieux et il est vrai que les
informations du pentagone se vérifie et
elle nous annonce au cours des dernières
48 heures la préparation de l'armée
russe d'ores et déjà déployé à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine comme vous le
décrivez depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant et nous annonce la relance
d'une vaste opération qui évidemment va
venir de l'est mais également du sud et
des opérations qui cette fois ci sont
nouvelles sur l'ouest de l'ukraine des
opérations aériennes justement vous êtes
au delà notre correspondant à washington
spécialiste des questions militaires sur
notre antenne pourquoi est-ce que la
russie commence à amener désormais des
bombardements du côté de l'ouest et a
semblé démarrer de nouveaux fronts oui
absolument c'était un scénario attendu
vous avez une guerre de ce genre
on en n'a pas observé depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale concrètement une pour
une raison simple parce que c'est une
c'est une guerre conventionnelle entre
deux armées conventionnelles un combat
de haute intensité des batailles de
chars contre des batailles de chars deux
armées modernes qui s'affrontent l'une
des règles qui régissent l'affrontement
de deux armées conventionnelles c'est la
bataille de la logistique et c'est ce à
quoi on assiste en ce moment c'est ce
qui justifie en tout cas ses frappes
ruiz sur la partie ouest de l'ukraine on
a beaucoup parlé de la base de ia vos
rives qui est cette plateforme
aéroportuaire qui a été frappé au cours
des dernières 24 heures et qui est la
porte d'entrée de l'indispensable
armement européen et américain qui
alimente la résistance ukrainienne il ya
eu une frappe importante avec plusieurs
dizaines de morts et une destruction de
matériel qui va manquer à l'armée
ukrainienne on observe ce phénomène
partout sur les axes qui ce qu'on
appelle des pénétrantes en tactique des
axes qui viennent de la pologne de la
roumanie de l'allemagne en gros les axes
logistiques qui alimente l'armée
iranienne en vivres et en carburant en
munitions le nerf de la guerre